[Música]
eu vi tudo certo eu venho lá e posso
nassim resíduo e peça a deus a graça de
enquanto viver e ver em uma comunidade
rural chamada acham de jardim município
de areia a 118 quilômetros aqui de joão
pessoa
nunca me conformei com a falta de tudo
sempre quis ter uma vida melhor do que
os meus parentes tiveram e desde muito
cedo comecei a trabalhar
era uma festa quando chegava a safra de
caju pra eu apanhar castanha e vender
era uma festa pra mim poder plantar no
sítio do meu avó uns pés de maracujá
eu passei a ser a maior criança
empreendedora de chã de jardim ea maior
produtora de maracujá criança com aquela
comunidade já viu
e aí começou o meu trabalho como boa a
moradora do campo a gente preza muito
pela religiosidade para fazer os
catecismo e logo nossos pais nos
colocaram pra fazer a primeira
eucaristia eu tenho oito anos
arrumar mais uns 15 meninas da minha
idade colocar a gente na igreja passa é
santo não viramos santo de geninho por
marca até sem que fizesse mas não teve
jeito de virar santo
fizemos a primeira eucaristia depois
passamos para participar do catecismo do
crisma já tava tudo acostumado todo
final de semana não está naquela
lenga-lenga paz é santa e não virá
avançando que quando a gente se crismou
montamos um grupo de jovens com o nome
de al
não faz a força se a união faz a força
do vidro outra coisa fazem é verdade
e aí começamos um trabalho e eu e mais
16 abilolado porque quem pensa diferente
dos outros é doido é abilolado no tenho
que fazer e eu e esses abilolado que
vocês estão vendo aí quando você a
bolada sozinho né
a gente começou um trabalho enquanto o
grupo de jovens rezando
mas a gente descobriu que a reza não
leva a salvação pra ninguém mas sim o
que a reza nos pede se a gente fizer o
que a reza pede pra gente fazer talvez
um dia a gente encontra salvação e eu e
meus amigos com 15 14 e 16 anos
percebemos que morávamos em uma
comunidade muito pobre que precisava de
tudo e que faltava tudo e nós começamos
um trabalho diagnosticando que tinha lá
todos os anos a gente fazia um
planejamento para o ano inteiro pra ver
qual família precisava de uma feira com
a família precisava de um trabalho com a
família precisava de um exame mais
apurado para a gente levar essas pessoas
para campina grande para poder salvar
muitas vidas e através de festas de
rifas de bingos
nós começamos a ajudar a comunidade chã
de áden e aí nós começamos a perceber
como é bom fazer o bem para as outras
pessoas
começamos esse trabalho mas o trabalho
que a gente mas nos encantava enfeitar
capela da gente a capela da gente tem
assunto instrumento tenha banheiro tem a
sacristia tenha microfone desse bonito e
aí um belo dia numa reunião dessa de
planejamento anual um dos nossos amigos
olhou pra gente disse
tudo que a gente fez até hoje aos olhos
de deus não vale de nada
numa trama que ele felipe não estava
dentro de uma capela e aí o inferno mais
cedo mais à vontade porque é tanto que a
gente trabalhava para ajudar aquela
comunidade e que a gente tenha feito não
vale de nada
aos olhos de deus e foi aí que ele diz
perto da minha casa tem um pessoal que
mora numa casa de taipa essa casa está
ameaçando cair sobre eles e se cai a
culpa é da gente porque ao invés de a
gente está enfeitando igreja nós
devíamos fazer uma casa dessas pessoas
ea partir daí a gente diz pronto no
próximo ano o nosso trabalho vai ser
fazer uma casa pra essa família carente
e ao longo desses anos nós conseguimos
dar duas casas de tijolo pra duas
famílias que moravam em casas de taipa
que não saber o que era uma casa pra nós
era uma simples casa pra eles um palácio
e aí começa vendo esse nosso trabalho
existia na comunidade chã jardim
o parque estadual mata do pau ferro e
muitas famílias desse parque que residem
lá dentro e viviam da criação da
plantação foram retiradas em 96 para
morar às margens da rodovia
deram para essas pessoas uma casa
construir uma fábrica de polpa de fruta
construir uma loja para vender até
artesanato e disseram a partir de hoje o
trabalho de vocês mudou
vocês não precisam mais sofrer plantando
criando nem fazendo nada
o trabalho de vocês agora é trabalhar
com o turismo com artesanato com polpa
de fruta
o problema é que não capacitar essas
pessoas e como essas pessoas em produzir
artesanatos e até então ninguém nunca
tenha ensinado essas pessoas a fazerem
um artesanato uma polpa de fruta e aí o
gestor da mata vê no trabalho da gente
nos convidou pra gente formar uma
associação é claro que a gente não quer
que a gente era o grupo mas bem quisto
mais bem vista da paróquia nós já queria
saber de associação mas ela arrumou um
curso de associativismo e pra convencer
nós ele disse o seguinte olha no curso
vai ter lan
aí as coisas começaram a melhorar de
duas em duas horas tem um lanchinho aí
nós formação no bom e no final desse
mesmo assim no final tem uma feijoada do
etá onde tem comida tem
gente nós fomos fazer o curso quando a
gente terminou aquele curso de
associativismo a gente percebeu que já
era uma associação
pelo menos de fato faltava existir de
direito e como a gente gostaria muito de
fazer bem fizemos um bem do carneiro em
menos de um mês já estava no cartório
registrando a associação para o
desenvolvimento sustentável da
comunidade chã de já tem o nome já dizia
tudo e aí nós percebemos que tínhamos
feito aquele curso de associativismo e
as portas estavam abertas pra gente
fazer mais cursos
nós fizemos 20 recursos numa seqüência e
os meninos e oito meninas besta quanto
professam a aula a pessoa quer fazer o
que o professor nos pede né então quando
a gente participa do curso em menos de
um mês a gente já estava colocando em
prática o que aquele professor tinha nos
dito e aí fizemos o curso de guias
roteiros e caminhadas e começamos a
receber as pessoas na mata do pau ferro
para fazer trilha o povo andava andava
de repente ficava cansado
de repente a gente percebeu que eles se
ficando cansado a gente de sopa
nós somos aqui 20 dias para cada pessoa
que vem aqui tem dia que vem uma turma
de 20 pessoas quase um guia para cada
pessoa então agora vamos nos dividir
vamos inventar agora o piquenique na
mata porque turística' turista tem que
sair dali contento então nós procuramos
na comunidade uma exceção às esteiras
procuramos saber quem tem um bolo
gostoso a tapioca gostoso gostoso uma
fruta gostosa pelo tenha graça nenhuma
a gente se viu as pessoas que acham
jardim o bolo comprado lá na cidade na
padaria e aí nós começamos fazendo o
nosso piquenique na mata
depois as pessoas que será agora a gente
peca ajeitar e cansado não tem problema
nenhum e vetamos dinâmica de relaxamento
cada uma tem um preço é claro
aproveitamos essa moça bonita que cantou
aqui pra vocês que canta lá na dinâmica
do relaxamento ea gente fecha os olhos
agora tudo em vão esquecer os problemas
e no final tem uma coisinha li ke ha
o pagamento era uma coisa agora vai ser
outra pra toda a comunidade usufrui
evitamos a dinâmica relaxamento mas na
frente da minha gente dizendo que estava
cansado minha gente
a análise não tem problema nenhum não
tem bicicleta a cavalo gata quem pode
pegar pra você ir andar de bicicleta e
de cavalo e aí desse jeito
inventamos também a oficina de
viveirista ea oficina de compostagem e
nesse momento a gente percebeu como é
bom fazer o bem para as outras pessoas
como é bom olhar no olho das pessoas e
perceber que somos responsável por
aquele sorriso de alegria estampada no
rosto dela
mas não paramos por aí existia nas
mulher na comunidade monte de mulher que
vive assistindo novela eu tive a alegria
de estudar em campina grande e terminei
meu curso
sou historiador e profissão se saia de
quatro horas de amanhã 4 e 6 voltava
duas horas da tarde
muitas vezes se fazem um lanche porque o
dinheirinho que meus pais me dava ou eu
fazia um lanche ao tirar xerox
eu prefiro tirar xérox tá certo que
quando eu terminei meu curso de vontade
de comer aquele papel tudo em ordem
eu me lembrava do pão de frango com
creme rosé que meus que eu tenho vontade
de comer na universidade não podia
levantar da rumam um crime você botar
naquela foi comer tudo em só de 8
terminar o curso
mas coloquei na minha cabeça eu nunca
vou sair da minha comunidade
o que eu tô aprendendo aqui o tempo que
levar para a comunidade chã jardim para
essas pessoas que me vêem passam todos
os dias que me dá uma carona umbigo que
me dá um lanchinho quando o voto
morrendo de fome com votado com meus
para os papéis né
e aí um belo dia deus sabendo do que eu
tenho no meu na minha mente me deu
alegria de ser professora para um grupo
de mulheres da comunidade chã já tem pra
ajudá las a ale ea escrever melhor
quando cheguei na sala de aula eu
comecei a fazer uma dinâmica onde eu
pedia para aquelas mulheres todos os
dias contar uma história de casa ou
escrever aí elas me mataram minha gente
porque elas nos textos que elas mandavam
pra mim
elas começaram a dizer que elas tenham
duas refeições na sua casa almoço
e janta e começaram a me perguntar se eu
não podia fazer alguma coisa para que
elas tivessem uma renda e sugerir um
artesanato já que tenha tantos turistas
na comunidade como eu ensinar essas
mulheres fazem artesanato
se eu não sei fazer nenhuma bola pra
ficar redonda mas a vontade foi tão
grande que procurei as pessoas pra
ajudar aquelas minhas alunas
as primeiras peças que fizeram rives as
segundas terríveis a 3º preze é tão feia
que tiver vergonha de levar para longe
mas eu levei as pessoas olhavam olhava
olhava nunca comprava uma mas depois de
uma consultoria melhoraram passando um
mês eu juntei o dinheiro daquelas
mulheres entrega na sala de aula naquele
dia a nossa aula sobre aquele dinheiro e
eu comecei a perguntar o que vocês
fizeram com o dinheiro de vocês uma
disseram comprei uma toalha outras eram
comprei um casaco contas eu comprei uma
coberta e eu dizia mais porque isso é
pra gente se lembrar um dia ficou no
recanto da parede não quis dizer no
final me chamou no recanto morrendo de
chorar
olhou pra mim e disse luciano você sabe
que eu fui a pessoa que menos ganhou só
receber oito reais mas os meus oito
reais do sena
hoje eu comprei pão mortadela e café e
hoje luciana os meus filhos tomar um
café com pão porque eu comprei eu tenho
estudado pra isso minha gente eu comecei
a ajudar aquelas mulheres vai escutar
isso
imaginem o tamanho da minha alegria
mas mesmo assim demos prosseguimento
ainda existia muita gente na comunidade
que precisava do trabalho tem uma
fábrica de polpa de fruta desativada
abrimos com a cara e com a coragem
mais uma vez chamado de doido porque
quem pensa diferente é louco
abrimos começamos a vender a polpa
começamos outra fonte de renda um belo
dia chegou o senhor tu no carro branco
de seu visitou a fábrica todo
foi mesmo de pergunta e eu mota de
contenta e terceiro vai comprar a
produção toda milhões
era um mapa uma espécie de vigilância
sanitária no final miguel intimação ou
de minha nossa senhora toda presa o que
foi que eu fiz mas na verdade era para a
gente melhorar
e aí passando dois anos e oito meses
trabalhando de forma voluntária para
tentar ajustar aquela fábrica o que foi
bom porque no final a gente recebeu o
selo de popa se fada
podemos até exportar mas a gente sabia
que a merenda escolar 30% tinha que ser
comprado ao agricultor familiar
tá certo que muitas muitas prefeituras
não queriam comprar da gente mas a gente
sabia da lei colocou debaixo do braço
foi até a prefeitura quando chegou lá a
gente disse ou compra ou a gente
denuncia o povo tem um método de
denúncia esse povo e aí não deu outra
começar a comprar hoje a gente vem pra
mais de seis prefeituras para a merenda
do estado e para outras instituições
começamos a vender popa na fábrica
começamos a perceber que tinha de
participar até oito pessoas e depois
aumentou para 80 tinha de parar 80
pessoas um dia a gente vendeu um free
história de pop agente disse ainda tem
na comunidade pessoas que fazem do sino
tenho de vender que fazem embora não
tenha de vender que pintou um pano de
prato que fazem boneca de pano não têm
onde vender
montamos a bodega tá vender popa e os
produtos da comunidade só nessa bodega
são mais de trinta pessoa que manda os
seus produtos praia
nessa época eu fiz o empretec e quando
você volta do empretec você vota
abilolado e dessa vez eu aceitei que eu
estava meio abilolado porque volta com a
idéia fixa de montar um restaurante sem
ter um tostão mas a vontade era tão
grande que quando cheguei com meus -
passei meus sócios não quiser o i outros
os pais não deixar mas pelo menos dois
coitado ter pena de mim prestou nome eu
tenho uma moto que se tudo der errado ou
venda na estrada da moto mas eu não vou
presa
aí fui montei o restaurante é o nome de
romaric e aí com esse propósito de
oferecer apenas o que a comunidade
todos nós passamos a ser o restaurante
que não serve refrigera que não serve é
free gerante só isso que a água para
garantir o trabalho dá pouco e tudo que
a gente oferece lá é produzido na
comunidade só traz de fora o que não é
produzido lá em chamas já tem e assim
nós despertamos o empreendedorismo
individual das pessoas pessoas passaram
até hortas pessoas passaram a criar
galinhas pessoas passaram a criar porcos
pessoas que passaram aqui a bob e obriga
todo mundo quem quiser na prova maria
vai comer bode frango porco galinha e
não não sei o que lá ao molho no seu que
isso não tem o que tem lá é as coisas
que a comunidade produz e dessa forma
lai jardim nós temos vários outros
empreendedores individuais
entramos em uma sociedade com o jovem e
montamos o camping o tel de barraca
jardim rural encantado outra menina com
vende milho no final de semana na frente
do restaurante outra vendedor sim outros
colocaram o caldo de cana ea semana
passada quatro meninos começaram a botar
papel na frente do carro das pessoas pra
ganhar o seu dinheiro
imaginem vocês se eu não tô morando no
melhor lugar do mundo e eu termino
dizendo a cada um de vocês que aqui
estão
agora é com vocês façam a parte de vocês
façam o melhor do que a gente fez é
possível viver no lugar onde a gente
mora com dignidade se assim fizermos se
procurarmos um jeito se nos apaixonamos
pelo que a gente faz se a gente buscar
os parceiros se a gente buscar estudar
não tenho nenhuma dúvida é possível
viver no lugar onde a gente mora com
dignidade encontra o seu jeito porque se
assim você fizer você vai ter uma
comunidade melhor uma rua melhor um
bairro melhor uma cidade melhor
estado melhor um país melhor que todos
nós nos orgulharemos de morar nesse país
chamado brasil
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]